my roving field correspondent Josephine
is standing by Josephine yeah you know
the hallways you're getting kind of
packed so i convince danny diggz join me
here in the hood room Danny dig of
Oregon State University welcome nice
name thank you very much for everything
i read that your specialty is in
enabling programmers what has changed in
the world of computing that they need
enabling yeah so my research is enabling
programmers to confidently and to safely
change very large computer programs out
there so I'm turning regular average
programmers into ober programmers who
can change very large software systems
and the only software systems were
successful out there in the real world
are those who keeps to keep changing you
know if I thought the season doesn't
change then it becomes obsolete and no
users want to use obsolete systems uber
programmers I like that a lot and and
the whole world is getting bigger and
you know bigger data sets or are
everywhere so can you give an example of
how automated changes in these large
data sets you know are used in the real
world yeah so my research group has been
automating a few kinds of this software
changes so I can give you a few examples
we've been working in the last few years
to semi automate with the help of the
program this is an interactive
automation process to semi auto made
programs to make them more efficient to
make them use a parallelism that is in
every computing device in laptops in
desktops in mobiles so all of these
devices have now multiple brains we call
the multi-core processing the software
doesn't know how to use multiple brain
so then the software doesn't get any
faster so that's what I've been
researching on the last few years you
know how can we adapt our software to
actually effectively make use of the
parallelism in hardware and to it should
improve the performance of soft well
speaking of mobile phones for example
people are using these phones to do more
more they surf the web they call up
video etc and sometimes it's pretty slow
and you're saying that these automatic
changes can actually make things faster
yeah so recently we started looking at
the specific domain of mobiles so Mobile
smartphones and all these mobile devices
are they have much limited computing
resources than the bigger cousins that
stops and the laptops that's why they
crashed sometimes yeah yet yet what you
see the the usage of the of the model of
the usage is like you know people are
switching to them and moving away from
desktop and laptops and most of the
usage out of these devices is going to
the network fetching content from the
web loading a page or loading dynamic
content that can take a long time so if
you are a program or you are not careful
on how you program this you can execute
a lot of these network or services you
can execute them on the main we call the
main user interface event thread which
will block the user interface and your
app will become unresponsive and you get
very frustrated and this is what causes
people to write bad reviews about absent
to uninstall the app and and we've been
helping programmers in having
programmers to improve the
responsiveness of the earth we've all
had that happen so thank goodness that
you are improving that and the thing is
your work if successful is actually
invisible to the end user that's the
point isn't it that well that's the
that's the sign of a success when when
you know computer science it's truly
successful when it's not on the first
page of New York Times but but when you
know everybody is using it is life
becomes the water and the air that we
breathe you know it's it's unnoticeable
everything go so smooth everything is so
responsive is so and when it's good news
for you yeah thank you so much Danny
that was great work by the way back to
you Chris